salut romain ça va qu'est ce tu fais
réserve mes vacances a fait voir ces
jolies fait plus classe et un village
vacances non cliniques
[Musique]
vous avez attendu ça toute l'année vous
avez torche et tout ce que vous aviez à
faire au boulot avant de partir le chien
dans son siège auto les enfants sont au
chenil
le plan est fait les valises sont prêtes
le gps est programmée la glacière et
plein de sandwichs le moment est enfin
arrivé
c'est les pus de vacances yes
oui mais là c'est la tuile là c'est pile
le moment que votre corps choisi pour
nous lâcher vous êtes malade pourquoi ça
arrive toujours au moment des vacances
ça je ne vous cache pas que on va
commencer par les choses évidentes c'est
le frappé au coin du bon sens les
vacances c'est quoi les vacances c'est
avant tout un changement de rythme et ça
votre corps et aime pas ça nous était un
petit peu à l'image de votre transit
intestinal
un rien vous des règles d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on est souvent constituée en
vacances une activité saran l'intestin
peu paresseux on oublie un peu les
légumes on pense pas forcément à boire
de l'eau alors qu'il fait chaud voilà on
se laisse aller tout ça c'est des trucs
plutôt cool mais qui ont un revers de la
médaille un peu dur de dur peu dur comme
du caca dur la constipation c'est de la
médecine obsession kaka c'est pas vrai
wahou sabaot on peut tout expliquer avec
des métaphores fécales romain tout tu
mentor alors merde tu vois bon bref
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet les
vacances on va se pencher un petit peu
sur la période qui précède c'est la
dernière ligne droite donc déjà on n'en
peut plus en plus on charge la mule pour
finir tout le boulot qu'on a à faire
avant de partir et en même temps on doit
préparer le départ autant vous dire
qu'on arrive le jour j complètement
épuisé surtout si on a vu des coups tous
les soirs pour profiter des beaux jours
en terrasse et dire au revoir aux potes
avant de partir en vacances
on manque de sommeil on a mal manger on
a picolé autant vous dire qu'on enferme
les vacances dans un piteux état et on
va continuer à affaiblir notre organisme
en modifiant nos habitudes en matière de
sommeil d'alimentation etc
pendant les congés donc on va se rendre
encore plus vulnérables à toutes les
saloperies qui traîne et justement des
saloperies qui traînent on va en croisé
plein et on va en croisé qu'on n'est pas
habitué à croiser le reste de l'année
dont contre lesquelles on n'est pas
vraiment armé alors quand je parle des
saloperies je parle pas des renoux qui
parle lui perfore dans le train ou qui
laissent leurs gamins vous jeter le
ballon dessus pendant que vous faites la
sieste un petit peu mais je parle
surtout des microbes des virus des
bactéries vous allez en croiser dans la
clim
dans les lieux publics plein de gens
donc une gerbe dans la bouffe etc tout
ça c'est susceptible de vous rendre
malade d'autant plus que selon certaines
théories le système immunitaire et
connaîtrait un petit coup de mou au
moment où l'on relâche la pression
alors attention tout ça ça reste de
l'ordre de l'hypothèse n'a pas été
validée scientifiquement mais il ya deux
psychologues néerlandais qui se sont
précisément pencher sur cette
malédiction des congés mal que vannes
wizzgo porte et à devine que roth
c'est leur nom merci à eux ils ont
établi une théorie sur ce qu'ils ont
appelé la maladie des loisirs ou la
maladie du temps libre selon leurs
recherches parmi les maladies qui
apparaissent le plus fréquemment quand
on arrive en vacances il y aurait la
migraine et on sait qu effectivement les
migraines
elles apparaissent plus facilement à
l'occasion d'un changement comme par
exemple un changement de rythme de
sommeil ou un repas sauter un repas à
prix plus tardivement etc
ça s'explique par le fait que le cerveau
des migraineux et plus équitable et plus
sensibles aux changements que celui des
autres on en avait parlé dans la vidéo
sur la migraine vous souvenez bien mais
globalement le cerveau ça reste une
petite bête sensible donc tout ça ça
reste valable dans une moindre mesure
pour un petit peu tout le monde
autre explication on aurait la capacité
de retarder l'apparition d'une maladie
quand on est sous pression et qu'on a
conscience que c'est pas vraiment le
moment d'être malade l'hypothèse avancée
mais là encore son véritable travaux
scientifiques pour l'étayer c'est que le
stress ça nous fait sécréter des
substances qui stimulent notre système
immunitaire dans un premier temps donc
on résiste mais qui l'affaiblissent dans
un deuxième temps donc on tombe malade
à terme on sait quand même que le stress
ça a un effet négatif sur la santé en
général et sur le système immunitaire en
particulier donc allez pas vous stresser
pour pas tomber malade
voilà pour les explications
physiologique mais vous vous souvenez
peut-être qu'on en avait parlé dans ma
vidéo le
pouvoir de l'esprit sur le corps
l'aspect psychologique est aussi super
important genre pour revenir sur le
dernier exemple c'est ça qui va
déterminer notamment quand selon vous
c'est pas le bon moment pour tomber
malade pour certains c'est pendant qu'on
bosse pour d'autres c'est pendant les
vacances
d'ailleurs pour être tout à fait précis
sur le sujet l'étude menée par nos amis
psychologue néerlandais dont je vais pas
répéter non elle a démontré que
seulement 3% des gens tombent plus
souvent malades en vacances que le reste
du temps donc on va se mettre d'accord
tout de suite oui les vacances c'est un
moment particulièrement propice aux
maladies
mais non on tombe pas toujours malade
juste avant les vacances ou pendant les
vacances un donc arrêter un petit peu
avec ça maintenant je suis encore mais
bon c'est quand même une réalité donc
voilà mes quatre conseils pour préparer
votre corps aux vacances
reposez-vous avant les vacances dormez
pour paris les épuiser le jour du départ
manger correctement et allez y mollo sur
le tapis rouge ayez une activité
physique régulière éviter l'effet tête
dans le guidon n'attendez pas le dernier
moment pour tout faire que ce soit au
niveau du dos ou des préparatifs pour
les vacances ça vous évitera de la
fatigue et du stress
vous avez compris l'idée c'est de pas
arriver en vacances complètement
ratatiner pour pas choper le premier
truc qui passe à et dernier truc vous le
savez peut-être pas mais si vous tombez
malade pendant vos vacances vous pouvez
vous mettre en arrêt maladie et décalé
vos congés si vous êtes salarié et que
vous tombez malade avant votre départ
vous avez le droit de reporter vos
congés payés après votre reprise du
travail
et si vous tombez malade pendant vos
vacances vous pouvez aussi les suspendre
six est prévu dans votre convention
collective donc renseignez vous voilà
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos en attendant profitez bien de vos
vacances si vous avez la chance d'en
prendre cet été prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout porté lire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]